yeah i thought about this 80s thing the
other day because we were at a festival
and i'm backstage and i looked around
and there was like a dude from another
rock band complaining about having a
peanut allergy and asking where the
vegan options were and if there was any
peanuts in the room at all what a [ __ ]
and i'm like
[ __ ]
vincent neal would be sickened by you
it's like [ __ ] the guy in nickelback
or something
you know what's somewhere crazy i talked
to chad from nickelback and he's
actually one of the cool ones
i think nickelback gets a bad rep
they're kind of like the go-to band to
be like they're they're gay
listen but if you don't think
[Laughter]
i tell you i tell you what
i can say this
i don't have a creed song i bump very
often at all but i can tell you that
rockstar still [ __ ] oh yeah yeah and
nickelback might make the best white
strip club music ever you're going to do
a white strip club and a chick that's
the size of the rail of that light over
there it's just slow thrusting
look at this photograph
that's like a [ __ ] go-to at the white
strip club yeah
it's worth saving she just she's safe
enough to go to gathering of the jungles
she's just slow thrusting
yes yes oh god